alors quand j'ai connu les maquereaux il
était même pas envisageable qu'il soit
président de la république et même je me
souviens pour vous faire une confidence
quand il me l'avait dit je croyais pas
je dis tu plaisantes
[Musique]
j'avais peur parce que vous savez moi je
suis animateur depuis plus de 35 ans et
le métier d'animateur et de chroniqueurs
c'est deux choses très différentes
chroniqueur vous êtes là en attend de
vous certaines choses souvent d'être
drôles ou de donner des informations etc
l'animateur y tient à l'émission il
donne la parole distribue la parole et
c'est un métier très différents alors je
me sens encore mieux cette année dans
tpm paix parce que je crois
effectivement retrouvé un peu ma place
on a tous un peu des rôles des
personnages
oui je m'y amuse et ça je crois que
c'est bien que ça se ressent
alors mon chroniqueurs préférés je vais
très clair et très direct c'est isabelle
morini bosc
je les aime beaucoup elle est brillante
on exerce de l'été le même métier elle
est également à la radio comme moi et en
sentant bien là le respect des artistes
le respect de son travail elle est très
rigolote elle est perchée et très peur
chez total chante c'est épouvantable
quand elle parle je comprends rien et
j'adore oui j'aimerais avoir une
émission à moi sur ces vite je n'ai pas
demandé les pas réclamé à personne mais
j'aimerais avoir une émission ou bien
sûr peut-être la co animé avec kelis
intérêts beaucoup cet or kelly qui est
vraiment gracieuse et sympathique
alors ma retraite je devrai apprendre
avant qu'on me l'a suggéré mais je pense
moi toujours arrêtée l'année suivante
voyez même cette année je pensais pas
resigné avec tpm penny la radio
peut-être que j'arrêterai en juin je
pense pas mais ce qui me fait peur dans
la notion de retraite c'est que quand
vous aimez la culture comme moi les arts
le cinéma le théâtre puis rencontrer ces
artistes qui vous font vivre et sans que
je crois que ça me manquerait beaucoup
trop donc pour le moment je continue
déjà très jeune je faisais des
interviews de personnalités
en fait j'ai toujours aimé rencontrer
les artistes pour parler d'eux parce que
je suis assez fasciné parce que je ne
suis pas un artiste et j'ai beaucoup
aimé rencontrer boubakary c'est tout ça
qui ne faisait pas partie de mon univers
franchement je sois heureuse comme ça à
l'air d'être avec jalil laisse tomber le
côté vous avez pleuré parce que j'ai
déconné lors d'un concert et il se
trouve que madame macro est venu vers
moi en me disant voilà je vous connais
de la télévision est extrêmement
sympathique et l'a appelée manuel
emmanuel vient voir il ya bernard
montiel emmanuel est arrivé et mehdi
abeid ma femme vous aime beaucoup on
vous aime beaucoup très gentil j'étais
très touchée très surpris et puis très
vite ils m'ont dit bon aller très bien
que dans se voit jeunes et des jeunes et
on a déjeuné ensemble et puis très vite
saleh comme parfois ça arrive on choisit
pas une espèce de communion de sympathie
qui se créent médiate sans penser au
pouvoir ni rien parce qu'il n'en était
pas question
alors quand j'ai connu les maquereaux et
n'était même pas envisageable qu'ils
soient président marc dolez et même je
me souviens pour vous faire une
confidence quand il me l'avait dit je
croyais pas je dis tu plaisantes présent
la république n'a pas de parti on te
connaît à peine en france et y souriez
parce qu'évidemment il avait déjà ses
idées et le mec est tellement brillant
tellement il est déjà des kilomètres
d'avancé sur toi que je me souviendrai
juste souri quand je dis ça écoutez je
suis jamais allé mais il se trouve que
c'est vrai que je suis bronzé bon je
suis d'origine cammas et
méditerranéennes ça c'est sûr un peu
espagnol je suis né au maroc donc
forcément j'ai la peau mate sur ma qui
ne serait ce qu'un peu pour empêcher de
briller ça y est ça fait plus bronzé
quoi mais j'ai jamais fait de point
soleil et je vous le déconseille
honnêtement je sais pas mais moi vous
savez métal et de passer des réveillons
tout seul et ça me gêne pas quand
j'avais mon chien
[Musique]